[Music]
it's time once again for the dr pepper
10 testosterone challenge
[Applause]
[Music]
all right here's how this works we asked
our fans to come up with manly
challenges for andy to attempt on our
show
and we had a ton of great suggestions at
teamcoco.com
manly
and we picked our eight favorite
manly challenges these are all coming
from the fans manly challenges for andy
to attempt right now live on our show
you folks ready for this
good
andy you ready
yes i am conan all right
these are all real suggestions from fans
the first one bench press two slabs of
bacon or even better how about andy
deadlifts two entire pigs let's see it
andy
okay
all right
this next one
no one said they couldn't be made out of
acrylic uh tie a windsor knot on a bear
that was a suggestion tie a windsor knot
that is not a realistic bear
but it is a realistic windsor knot very
nice
that's two all right here's next andy
cut down a tree and make something
useful out of it cut down a tree and
make something useful out of it go
boom umbrella umbrella that's
fine
now
here's the next one
throw a mannequin into a dumpster
all right
it's in yeah
[Applause]
all right hold on wait
how is that manly
okay he's clearly been
very nice
getting a little back swing here's one
andy get ready it says hit a home run
with a hoagie that was a suggestion
[Music]
[Applause]
there it is wow at the warning track
yeah i
could have sworn you hit it into the
floor
but the footage doesn't lie all right
here's the next one beat up two ninjas
beat up two ninjas
[Music]
apparently not very good ninjas uh
check this one okay watch the scene from
the lion king where mufasa dies without
crying it's a suggestion
long live the kid
[Music]
all right
he didn't cry
and your final
your final manly challenge as uh
submitted by a fan get tattooed by a
bear that was an actual suggestion so go
for it there we go same crappy bear
[Applause]
yeah yeah get over here very nice job
standing here with my shirt open yeah he
guess he shaved you before he tattooed
you
very nice job with his claw who cares
we'll be right back ladies and gentlemen
american sniper author chris kyle is
here stick around
[Applause]